io non so ma perché non so fischiare
porte di colore
[Musica]
cruz
waiting auto
io posso usare pietro come animale
impossibile connettersi ai server tua
madre errore di connessione è quella
lettera di hogwarts non ricevo manconi
giochi mida impossibile brunita era
tutti ragazzi vedrete questo video sono
felice io ci siamo su howard nostre
consegnava e ci siamo su harry potter
hogwarts misteriche è un gioco di harry
potter che mi avete consigliato a tutti
ma non c'è da ieri che anche mia madre
mi ha detto di giocare a sta roba
scegli il personaggio strega o mago mago
a si può cambiare che bello beh allora
non è che mi somiglia moltissimo però
non è che potevo fare al meglio di così
diciamo che questo è il massimo jamila
cosa mi ha fatto scegliere che sono un
uomo quindi va bene e avanti diagonale
che siamo così si muove scusa ma io
click sulle persone ok ciao ciao
sto cliccando non funziona ok ciao mi
chiamo rowan cannes e adesso te ne rollo
una anche tu stai ti stai preparando per
scuola di magia e stregoneria di
hogwarts
stavo girando a porta palazzo mi son
ritrovato a diagonale è così che domanda
è ma diagonale e disorientante non so da
dove cominciare
veramente ho visto talmente tante volte
il film che so anche dove andare a
cagare a diagonale prove posso aiutarti
io ho letto storia di hogwards anni fa
scegliere nome e cognome ok
l'app sono serio metto il mio vero
perché voglio dire cosa succede se
stavolta voglio farla seria quindi metto
il mio nome e cognome fa mica host 1
farvi capire che cosa si mi chiamo
lorenzo ostuni continua a fissare la mia
lettera di accettazione da quando è
arrivata mi fai vedere la tua gentile
lorenzo o dio santo bene quanto tempo
per quanto atteso questo momento gentile
lorenzoni siamo detti di informarla che
ha diritto a frequentare la scuola di
magia e stregoneria di hogwarts
qui è accluso al troverà l'elenco di
tutti i libri di testo
minerva né gradito magnifico vorrei
diventare capo scorreva diventare
caposcuola cosa credi che dovrei
prendere lorenzo la dose di eroina una
sciarpa maglione se un maglione serio un
bel cappello arra se vuoi diventare
caposcuola mettiti un cappello perché
quei capelli li non c'e lo diventi tu
dovresti prendono una bacchetta da
olivander andiamo a prendere le
bacchette ragazzi la bacchetta e la
bacchetta a scegliere il mago non il
mago a scegliere la bacchetta è un po
come il pene
sei tu a sceglierlo ti trovi con un pene
speriamo sia giustamente funzionante non
riesco a credere di essere da olivander
è qui che coprono tutti i loro prima
pacchetto salve signor al evander faccio
vedere dove che bello l'iva
tutti dicono che qui per riceve la sua
prima bacchetta dico bene si dammi la
bacchetta di sambuco corda di cuore di
drago 9 pollici e rigida via la gt open
a devo agitarla sul telefono
va bene ma ecco infatti vanno i fogli
all'aria quindi non è la bacchetta
giusta non è colpa sua e la bacchetta a
scegliere il mago è chiaramente questa
non fa per lei
ricordo che suo fratello suo fratello ma
fra io sono figlio unico fece esplodere
il mio calamaio preferito va bene
conosceva mio fratello io non ho
fratelli cosa dici legno di acacia
nucleo di crini di unicorno 12 pollici
flessibile e quelli che non è andata più
lunga avevo detto io
[Musica]
c'è poi mente se la bacchetta funziona
ti ritrovi impregnato di chanel
splendido sono molto curioso di vedere
che strana scegliere anche io se mi fate
arrivare ad hogwarts vada adesso non
vedo l'ora di vedere cosa sarà capace di
fare va bene canna per che cosa strani
che ti sei messo in testa ti piace il
mio cappello sì il fatto è che non ho
amici ebbe con quel cappello zio cosa
pretende puoi essere amico mio no per
favore non prendiamo gente stupida tra
gli amici non credi che sia troppo
strambo la gente vissuto la pensa così
la pensa esattamente così stammi lontano
grazie dicono lo stesso di me ma non è
vero
mio fratello e jacob ostuni box ha
corrotto o quanto brutto l'accostamento
jacob al cognome ostuni non sapevo di
avere un fratello che si chiama se jacob
lo stesso jacob ostuni che è stato
espulso dal guasto avrei infranto le
regole non ha parlato molto sulla
gazzetta del profeta
va beh posso andarmene via visto che
jacob ostuni è stato preso di mira
perché anzi stato espulso proprio siamo
arrivati forse arriviamo ad hogwarts se
dio vuole negati ad howard
ti prego dimmi di sì o il treno
la capilungo treno per hogwarts
oh che bello siamo arrivati cerimonia di
smistamento di smistano nelle case lega
vai vai vai che adesso sono curiosissimo
di vedere due mi buttano spero in tutti
quanti sperate che io sia un sempre
verde io lo so però non sono un
sempreverde io sono di base dovrei
essere tassorosso poi non so come mi
smista benvenuti ad howard
dobbiamo stare tutti gli allievi del
primo anno nelle loro case le quattro
case si chiamano grifondoro dei
coraggiosi e impavidi bra che bello che
hai silente tasso frasso corvo nero
serpeverde negli anni che faccia piton
vero che tutti voi sarete valide
aggiunte ai loro ragni ok adesso ostuni
lorenzo che è bello e l'altro questo
momento nella mia vita smistate i miei
amici molto interessante non ne vedo uno
così da molto tempo
dovetti collo ah sì ora capisco
sarà meglio fare anche i fattori tasso
frasso lo sapevo grazie siete tutti
contenti voi di tasso fra un tasso
frasso non posso crederci andiamo nella
sala comune di tasso fra asso vai
ciao amici intanto non vi crede nessuno
che state studiando lo so che non state
studiando o che belli colorito sopra
che meraviglia ora one minchia pensavo
di essermi liberato di te non è ricaduto
dal treno non eri stato investito non è
rimasto incastrato nella colonna del
binario 9 trequarti
vuoi che ti racconti nei dettagli la
storia della nostra casa no e assurdo
anche tu sia qui dopo che quel pazzo di
tuo fratello si è fatto e si sveglierà
di sotto la verità sopra solo radio se
muoio nava da kedavra nel culo me lo
deve dire subito non ho scelto io di
essere assegnato a tasso frasso certo
non siamo stati noi a scegliervi vada
che vada via
cosa ti attira di più lorenzo trovare
mio fratello ma chi se ne frega lezione
di incantesimi andare a lezione di
incantesimi ragazzi lezione di
incantesimi anche perché non ho ancora
neanche uno molto bene ostuni prendi
posto la lezione sta per iniziare
scommettete che wingardium leviosa la
prima cosa che ci fanno imparare
oggi impareremo incantesimo
importantissimo l'ha chiamato accendi
bacchetta è una magia che si utilizza in
luoghi oscuri ad esempio se si esplora
una stanza buia e lumi a ecco non ho mi
accendi bacheca e accendi a bacchetta
accendi bacchetta sarebbe lupus allora
vada kedavra cos'è ammazza persona
l'uomo ma lo devo dire al microfono
basta che
trascino non devo dire la magia armi fai
smanettare sullo schermo o la domanda
per voi vediamo se conoscete la risposta
sì cosa crea l'incantesimo lupus tua
madre nuda o no tortine visu cacao luce
l'hanno fatto per ebeti sto gioco per
cos'è un quiz magnifico grazie
ora provate voi ricordate lupus lupus
lupus tenta di lanciare l'incantesimo
tenta l'angelica tesi ma me lo fai
tracciare dire al microfono no se non
sta attento finito per cavare un occhio
a qualcuno o finalmente lo farà il
simbolo di axwell ingrosso axwell in gru
mousse quella che bello il mio amico noi
fatto signora sony è la migliore
esecuzione gli accenti bacchetta che ho
visto da tempo per il primo anno pensate
come stanno messi gli altri
nokia difficoltà che succede ma sento il
basilisco nei nei muri aspetta ma con le
roman st farneticando con un 7 verde
ammettilo non posso di che sono la
strega più potente di hogwarts ne sposa
allontanati da lui ti credi di essere io
sono lorenzo lorenzo è l'unico che può
dire di essere il miglior mago lorenzo
adesso ho capito di sei quello che fai
video su youtube ma se lorenzo studi
fuori jane tuo fratello impazzito a
svergognato la sua casa si è fatto
espellere e non si è saputo più niente
di lui chi sei tu merula smiled allieva
di sempre vedere il primo anno la
migliore strega di hogwards dovrei porre
fine alle sue sofferenze prima che tu
rovini hogwarts non ha cercato di fare
tuo fratello o arrivato piton ostuni
denuncia possesso sapevo che li avresti
creato guai ma cosa ho fatto
vai a lezione di pozioni e se sì grato
che non ti mando in punizione va bene
grazie per avermi difeso lorenzo prego
andiamo a pozioni ma dei parchi cedibili
no ero nel fondo messico dove andato ho
trovato nel fondo mestica andiamo a nola
di passione professor piton salve sono
tucson grandissimo estimatore
questa è la tua prima lezione di
funzioni e dallo sguardo concentrato che
hai potrebbe benissimo essere l'ultima
segui per imparare la sottile scienza
lesa parte dei creare pozioni posso
insegnare come stregare la mente
irretire i sensi e perfino mettere un
fermo alla morte trappola licenzia
malamente tenere la bocca chiusa mi ha
sentito dalle micro sappiate che esigo
la perfezione perché ci saranno gravi
conseguenze per chi mi deluda la madonna
credi di essere tanto speciale il manto
insuccesso è già assicurato story senti
brutta tocco voi la faccia dentro il
pentolone ignora la lorenzo dopo essere
stati rimproverati d'affitto ma dobbiamo
preparare questa passione perfettamente
ok faccio io
per iniziare la porzione dovete avere
una tecnica perfetta guardate me ma non
ti sei rimboccato le maniche ha fatto
solo il gesto ma quelle tavernello cos'è
quella roba lì usate le lumache cornute
non le altre le lumache della mia ex non
costringetemi a ripetere concentratevi
finite la porzione quanto prima voglio
vedere quanto siete scadenti nella
preparazione della ricetta mamma mia che
fiducia che ci ha piton lancia
occhiataccia lancio occhiatacce ha
bisogno di miglioramento ma come ha
aggiunto la polvere di bulbo tubero
youtube ero questa mi pare inizio di
inalazione esplosiva a causa del bo bo
tubero non è che non fa che non esploda
sono un casino esplosiva signor piton
non avresti mai dovuto essere ammesso
nella mia aula ostuni in qualche modo si
persino peggio di tuo fratello 10 punti
in meno tasse france ma cosa hanno fatto
niente
ma dai cos'è da dire intra difesa
menu la mia sabotato ha subiti la
responsabilità della tua incompetenza o
studi davvero no professore ostuni e
folle quanto il fratello è altrettanto
motivato a rovinare tutta hogwarts
ho perso dieci punti della casa di tasso
fra so cosa succederà quando tornerò
nella sala comune vita sopra su va ai
ragazzi possiamo concludere qui per oggi
direi per ora non sembra per niente male
però che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi io
concludo che questo episodio di miss
hogwarts mister i nomi di come si chiama
però vabbè se vi sia piaciuto come
succedeva più certo punto mi piace
agitare colpire anche ai social comini a
descrizione sono questi schiavi e
agitare a colpire
[Musica]